Yoga joke around years we have four
seasons winter winter winter and
construction powerful forces have
aligned to turn more than 1000 acres of
Wisconsin farm land and family homes
into an LCD screen manufacturing
facility folks called best known as the
maker of Apple's iPhone they're coming
into Wisconsin with an unbelievable plan
like we've never seen people our village
is in the process of purchasing millions
upon millions of dollars of property in
order to give it to a private
corporation pin know again
Jimmy thank you I'm glad to see Paul
Ryan's keeping track of millions of
billions state and local governments
have offered four point five billion
dollars in subsidies and tax breaks in
exchange for a promise of thirteen
thousand jobs and billions in tax
revenue eventually taxpayers may not see
the benefits until two thousand forty
three and the local government is tasked
with securing the land by summer's end
using any means necessary but some
residents aren't giving in without a
client how can they take my house to me
it's about stealing it's beautiful I
mean it's very quiet which is nice the
Sun sets out here are amazing every
night I'm saying look at this guy it is
so pretty
we just built this home we're at the top
of our budget Kim and Jim Mahoney bought
this parcel of land in 2009 and then
spent the next eight years building
their dream home from scratch
they just moved in last year with their
twelve-year-old daughter when we plan to
build this home we picked out every
finish every feature this is where we
plan to live forever
last October the Mahoney's learned from
a local news report that their small
rural village of Mount Pleasant would be
the site of the new manufacturing
facility kim mahoney says she heard from
her local councilman three days later
jim magnet called me on october 7th
and informed me that they would be
acquiring our property under eminent
domain i said i'm willing to sell my
property but you cannot take it
eminent domain is the legal term to
describe the process of taking property
from a private owner to facilitate a
public use like construction of a road
or a bridge but how broad is public use
in 2005 the Supreme Court ruled that the
Connecticut town of New London was
justified in seizing the land of
homeowner Suzette Kela in order to then
hand it over to the pharmaceutical giant
Pfizer on the grounds that it would
develop the property in a way that
boosted the fortunes of this fallen
seaport town the Pfizer project was
never built and this is how the lot
where kilos house once stood looks 13
years later public backlash led 43
states including Wisconsin to enact
legislation protecting property owners
from eminent domain for private projects
this is our constitutional rights being
trampled on Joe Janicek and his wife Kim
can look out their window and see
bulldozers digging up land right behind
their backyard
they gobbled up all of the big parcels
of property to offer all this land for
free to the Fox [ __ ] and then all you
have left are these little one acre two
acres three acre parcels with the homes
on so you have to basically squash the
little pebbles that are left behind and
how do you do that you intimate domain
them and you take it their house is just
feet from a public road that will be
expanded to six lanes likely leaving
them little legal recourse since
Wisconsin law doesn't protect homeowners
against taking property for new road
construction but in post Kela Wisconsin
the Mahoney's have a fighting chance
their home is hundreds of feet from a
major road so the state can't force them
to relinquish ownership so easily local
government officials however think they
might have a way it's called blight
which is traditionally used to condemn
worn down or crime ridden areas but in
this case means that the area's
residential zoning is outdated how did
it get that way because the government
of Mount Pleasant changed it to
accommodate Foxconn if the village just
has to rezone the area to Business Park
and call these homes blighted and take
the property and give it to someone else
how our our private property rights ever
protected 18 family homes remain in the
area seven of which are involved in a
federal lawsuit against the village of
Mount Pleasant we believe we are
following the law of the state of
Wisconsin
Ellen Markovitz is Mount Pleasant
attorney overseeing the Foxconn deal
he's partnered with project director
Claude Loyce a consultant with a firm
the local governments paying a $20,000 a
month fee which in part goes to cover
the cost of acquiring land Mount
Pleasant will issue between 700 and 800
million dollars in bonds to help finance
the project which are supposed to be
repaid with additional property taxes
after the Foxconn plant
boosts land values Royce was involved in
a similar deal in Illinois in which a
village about the size of Mount Pleasant
committed millions of dollars to pay for
a golf course development that later
went bang
cruft you were involved in a bond deal
in northern illinois more or less
bankrupted a town is there any worry
that that could happen here I just did
my job the investors yeah the economy
would you know took a turn so yeah so
there's no similarities between this
situation in that situation nope Mount
Pleasant is going to be on the hook for
this money for the next 30 years the
people in Mount Pleasant had no choice
in Foxconn coming here this was not
something that was put to a vote wasn't
put to a referendum kelly gallagher
founded a better Mount Pleasant a
community group that's been fighting
eminent domain abuse and pushing for
transparency around the Foxconn deal she
says that several other large companies
including Amazon have opened factories
in the area the difference is that these
companies bought the land on the open
market without the threat of eminent
domain what's different in this case is
Mount Pleasant is actually acting as the
real estate broker on behalf of Foxconn
and not for a small amount to land the
concept of eminent domain is very
interesting in this discussion because
if Foxconn had worked with a real estate
developer to purchase the land that
person would not have the authority to
subject people to eminent domain only a
municipality can do that only Mount
Pleasant can do that why does the
government have to be involved in buying
the land I suspect that one of the
practical reasons is the magnitude of
what needs to be done government is able
to work more quickly and more
efficiently believe it or not in this
area than the private sector could the
private sector is easily turned away
even during the option period if you are
under the impression that the people
that you've talked to are arguing about
this from a perspective that they really
want to stay in their homes I can tell
you that they have not told you the
whole truth every one of those property
owners is more than willing
with their property for this project
once they're paid what they define as
the fair value for their property why
not just negotiate something that both
parties can agree on instead of using
the crowbar of eminent domain well that
would only be considered as an absolute
last resort if all other reasonable
means fail is that really a fair
negotiation though if you have that in
your toolbox no because people have the
legal right in Wisconsin to resist your
taking of their property the court will
determine whether we have a right to
take your home they're saying this is
what we're going to give you and if you
don't like that deal you're free to hire
a lawyer and sue us that is in complete
contrast to how the free market is
actually supposed to work the factory is
in the district of house Speaker Paul
Ryan once considered a champion of the
free market Republican Scott Walker
shepherded the deal in a public press
conference he seemed hazy on the
project's basic details Fox comm and
Sony and all the other great can
sharpshooting I blew it again I got a
package of that and even seemed unsure
about the company's name
Foxconn Foxconn Foxconn Foxconn but the
Fox Scott team has been Walker completed
the deal which includes the 4.5 billion
dollars in tax incentives with a
hand-written agreement in which he
abruptly raised the jobs estimate being
discussed at the time from 3,000 to
13,000 another cause for concern is fox
khan's history of pulling out of similar
deals both domestically and abroad the
impetus for this project is in part
driven by politics Walker says President
Trump himself met with Foxconn execs
during a factory tour in Wisconsin and
then on the helicopter ride out was
flying over Mount Pleasant when his
chief of staff asked what that spot was
down there Wright's filled him in and he
told Terry and the others it would be
nice to build something like that right
in that area in southeastern Wisconsin
so that's exactly what we're doing here
today proponents argue that the Foxconn
deal will more than pay for itself and
with the taxpayer subsidies including a
17 cents on the dollar payroll tax
credit create thousands of jobs with a
median income of $54,000 a year why
should I have to subsidize those jobs
and give up my home in my land it just
doesn't seem fair
in early May Mount Pleasant Community
Development Authority convened for a
final vote to approve the plan to blight
the remaining areas needed to complete
the Foxconn development deal you are
negotiating on behalf of a private
corporation against your own residents
and for that you all should be ashamed
where am I going to live now that you
want to take away my home of 28 years
I've taken much pride in my home and
property for 15 years now I paid my
taxes as required made many improvements
and how you want to condemn it all like
a slob
saying that this area is blighted is
beyond me we didn't ask for this you
brought Foxconn to us and all we want is
to be treated fairly and equally how do
you look out at these people what
disgust months they think of you
everything that they work for everything
that they thought through to give us the
right to hold a deed that says nobody
nobody can take this from us and yet
here we are
the thought of lighting the property
because it's farmland it's absurd it's
unheard of thank you a single board
member voices his objection this is an
abuse of power because it forces selling
property against the will of owners so I
urge everybody to examine the facts and
examine their conscience and forward to
kill this plan here and out before we
send it to the village
but the crowds reactions ways no one the
deal is done as the board votes to
approve the development plan and then
abscond to closed session the biggest
victim in this is our daughter we're
gone at least two to three nights a week
going to various meetings and there's
times where she says you know can we not
talk about Foxconn today and and it's
really not fair to her to have to go
through this we finally got to a place
where we have a nice home in a nice area
and we can't enjoy it if we are
unsuccessful in acquiring all the
property that we need voluntarily
through agreement and we must as a last
resort use eminent domain those persons
who have a different opinion than we do
will be able to raise that issue and a
right to take challenge and one of two
things will happen either they will win
or they will lose homeowners and the
local government are at a standoff the
legality of Mount Pleasant effort to use
eminent domain to benefit a private
company will likely be decided in court
in the coming months and years if the
village of Mount Pleasant doesn't
negotiate with us fairly we will sue
them it may be at the cost of ending up
that we will eventually still have to
move we're willing to fight and if that
takes five years like it did for Suzette
kilo then we're up for the fight
[Music]